كل دوله مسؤوله عن مهمه
تنميه تنميه المحليه وبالتالي نعرف ان
للازمه الانسانيه الاثار على المدى الطويل
ولكن هذه الدول المتاثره ليست طرف النزاع
بالتالي يجب ان تتكبد ثمنا عاليا بسببها
تقوم بعض الاطفال باستعانه بتدابير احاديه
والضغط باعلى المستويات لكن ذلك لا يساوي
المساله بل يقوض سلاسل الامداد اكثر ويزيد
من حده الازمه الماليه والغذائيه وازمه
الطاقم نامل ان الاطراف سوف تتخذ تدابير
مسؤوله ولا تستغل هذه التدابير الاحاديه
اما مبادره تصدير الحبوب في البحر الاسود
والاتفاق بين الامم المتحده وروسيا حول
تصدير المواد الغذائيه والاسمده فتتسم بكل
الاهميه بما يضمن ان امن الغذائيه عبر
العالم ويجب ان تنافذ بشكل كامل وفاعل
وبشكل متوازن ايضا سيدي الرئيس
لن يكون دربو للسلام باليسير ولكن بغض
النظر عن مدى تعقيد هذه الظروف يجب الا
نفقد امالنا بالسلام او نوقف جهودنا من
اجل السلام بشان المساله الاوكرانيه تقف
بلادي دائما الى جانب السلام والحوار ونحن
جاهزون للعمل مع الاطراف جميعها بما يعزز
حلا سياسيا للازمه الاوكرانيه وبما يؤدي
الى احلال السلامه في اقرب الاجار شكرا
جزيلا